monsieur bonjour sébastien gonzalez de
la cpam des yvelines
je me permets de vous contacter pour
vérifier les documents que vous avez
concernant le transport que vous êtes en
train d'effectuer
donc si vous avez la prescription
médicale ce type de contrôle sébastien
gonzalez enquêteurs à la cpam en réalise
presque quotidiennement aux portes des
hôpitaux ou des cliniques au programme
vérification de la prescription médicale
du patient de la présence du macaron
conventionnés sur le pare brise et de la
trousse de soin des éléments
indispensables au remboursement du
transport par la caisse d'assurance
maladie
si le taxi admettant n'a pas la
prescription médicale un moment du
transport
on peut faire un refus lorsqu'il nous
transmet la facture
par exemple s'il n'a pas le macaron
aussi n'a pas la trousse de secours
on peut entamer une procédure
conventionnelle un taxi conventionné
prend en charge les clients et est
ensuite remboursée par la sécurité
sociale
pour ce chauffeur le transport
médicalisé représente 30% de son
activité quotidienne tout à fait normal
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'abus et surtout en ce moment on parle
beaucoup du trou de la sécu donc
normalement n'y a pas de souci là-dessus
après après il ya des règles à respecter
une convention question avec la sécu
appartement le respect qui a participé
depuis 2011 le service de lutte contre
les abus et les fraudes et centralisées
dans cet espace
chaque jour 18 agents à la manière d'un
détective privé repère des fraudes en
tous genres arrêt de travail non
respectés fausses déclarations de
revenus pour obtenir des demandes d'aidé
sociale mais aussi des actes fictifs des
professionnels de santé
l'exemple qu'on a lues sur quelqu'un qui
avait fraudé sur ses avis d'arrêt de
travail ont été qu'un monte à 58 milles
euros de préjudice sur un professionnel
de santé en général on est sur une base
de 20 à 40 mille euros d'un nul mais ça
peut monter on a eu l'exemple un
infirmier qui a été condamné pour
l'instant première instance et qui a eu
cette somme il rôde condamnation chaque
année ce service traite entre 550 et 600
dossiers sur le département
après enquête 70% des sommes à payer
sont récupérées soit plus de un million
deux cent mille euros